hey what's up beautiful people bar
always tells me he's ready and this time
I caught him in the accident no I was
ready I was literally drinking the
coffee welcome to another episode of get
close I am Geo and I'm Bart making all
the goddamn noise
so I got this German cup at a thrift
store and I freaking love it I'm kind of
scared to inquire too much about his
history but I love the shape why because
it's German and I like that
um it feels like it could be like old
school German you know what I'm saying
like like when the Germans were all
right okay so but maybe it's old school
German but what I like about this cup it
feels like there's a vacuum inside so
any liquid I put in whether it's hot or
cold it stays at for a long time I'm
really happy I got this yeah you got
like four of them and then when you pick
them I was like why those are the minute
I thought how heavy this was I was like
this is a [ __ ] Stein player
okay player
um so today I want to talk about
um something that I've been dealing with
that I didn't even know I was dealing
with because you concealed it so good
for me yeah I concealed it from you yes
or maybe I just don't pay attention to
that much wow okay so you know how we
have a son right remember that guy okay
I love him five years old yep super like
lights up the room everyone thinks he's
super cute
um you know my favorite phrase about him
is so far which one
so um when he got a stripe in jiu jitsu
he was so proud of himself and then
literally like the next day or two he
probably had one of the hardest recent
Jiu Jitsu practices of his life
and because he banged his head on the
ground and was I there no okay and I saw
the coach like really like walk him
through it you can do it like this is
you know like when things are tough this
is like what you have to do to keep
pushing forward and we want to make the
tough easy and all that and I see him
kind of like have his assistant coach
yeah coach the rest of the class while
he goes and gives him extra attention so
I was like oh man that's really really
cool of them because
um taika is one of those guys that kind
of needs a little bit more motivation
especially when the going gets tough
he's not one of those super emotional
yeah he's not gonna just like oh I'm
just gonna trust it out he's not one of
those kids so he needs like that extra
push so afterwards I texted him I was
like Hey like I really really appreciate
that um I think that was something that
he really needed and I'm glad that he
had a big owie and he was able to
overcome the owie and finish
um strong it's been strong finished
class positive yeah and then what he was
saying he goes like yeah like anytime
something that's really hurtful or kind
of like like uh traumatizing or
challenging like that that's a learning
moment and you want to help them get
past it especially someone and this is a
phrase that I like the most especially
when he is the funnest kid in class oh
oh like literally everything that he's
like weird naked chokes shrimping break
Falls he finds a way to make everything
fun he's laughing everyone's laughing
and so I think when he like gets hurt
and he's crying then it kind of brings
the whole thing down so I think for him
to go like not they can't let the
funnest kid in class give up yeah yeah
and so that made me feel really CUNY
because he to me he like just seems like
such a ball of Joy everywhere he goes
yeah he really is a ball of Joy
um and that's that's what we love about
him that's what everyone loves about him
but with that like with the good comes
the bad right because he's always
playful and fun we all understand time
and place right yeah and sometimes it's
the wrong time and it's the wrong place
like school yeah like school or like his
curiosity will get the best of them you
know like he uh what was he trying to do
oh I was taking a shower this morning
and we have like the glass shower case
yeah so he comes he grabs a door handle
and he like puts his [ __ ] 45 pounds
on it and he just like tries to like
like Propel himself up yeah like what
are you doing dude this is [ __ ] glass
he goes I just wanted to see what would
happen or like he'll get a water bottle
and then he's squeezing the water bottle
to like the water is rising all the way
to the top of the where you drink out of
and he's like like just testing it like
how far do I need to squeeze it before
it just spills and like brother like
come on dude like not right now we're
like in the car you're next to Dad we
can crash around like don't play like
that dude
so there's just all these things that
you know make him a fun loving dude and
then at the same time I'm like God damn
it man you're giving me so many [ __ ]
gray hairs I see like a wrinkle every
week just because of this guy now we're
at the phase where we're doing homework
and by we I mean him and I
and when I'm doing homework with him I
only have him for like maybe like five
minutes honestly I I like right now
specifically with writing he's like
writing all his lowercase and uppercase
letters
and like yes there's a lot of repetition
right because it's it's you gotta get
your reps in right Meathead yeah you
gotta get your reps in volume exactly
um so he'll do the first to perfectly no
problem
and I'm like yes dude and I'm clapping
I'm making a big deal out of it the next
one literally the next one I feel he's
gone I'm like dude tiger where did you
go man and I was telling you last night
I'm like like he's gone like I I've
never experienced that
um because you are someone that has told
me that has has been diagnosed with ADHD
but I don't see it like I just see you
have extreme Focus or that's what I'm
saying maybe I don't pay attention to
you but now with taika I feel like he
has the same thing because I'm like one
minute he's here and physically he's
with me but like the next minute
physically still here but mentally
somewhere else he's gone and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on I don't know
how to deal with that he has ADHD for
sure well how do you know for sure based
just on the way he acts I can tell
what's ax like what acts are we talking
about so because for me it's like kid
Behavior I haven't been a kid in a long
time and I don't I'm not around kids to
know that like that fool is different so
the clearest example is how I'd like to
explain ADHD from someone that has ADHD
to someone that doesn't quite understand
what ADHD is me so it's they call it
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
right that's the phrase and I think
inside the phrase the D where it says
attention deficit it's not so much
um
a lack of attention
it's just it's very wide but shallow
whereas the common person I think is
more focused kind of like a like a laser
right it's like the common person it's
like okay sit here then it goes boom sit
here for 10 minutes and then they're
like okay and you can almost feel
they're like Roots sink in are you
talking about like how you talking about
people without ADHD like you know how do
you know that because I've grown up with
good kids my whole life I see okay so
growing up with good kids I see them and
I go man I wish I could do that but as a
kid I felt like I was such a bad kid
like bat bar bat bar why can't you do
that and then as I got older and I
understood what it was I was just like
that's just not the way my brain
operates ah so that's literally what
happens yes yes like remember we took
that uh that neural test yeah we went to
like some neuro Camp gyms oh yeah he was
like a professor at UCLA yeah and then
so we sit in front of the computer and
we're tested on our attention span and
um like the mouse is calibrated so that
like how fast you click it because that
means that you're really paying
attention or how many times you fidget
with it like it's testing all of that
like your eye movement
um and obviously like the test itself is
testing all of that yeah and I think for
you it was like immediate he was like oh
you have ADHD and mine was like a
perfect score because I was just like
sitting there and it's literally 10
minutes of you just sitting there like
focusing on the number one and every
time you see number one you click it but
there's like number two number three one
two one two and you're just clicking and
it's just so mundane yeah I mean you
could tell even when attack is with his
cousins it's like you know when we're
all family time it's like all right
lunch time and then we always go like
youngest to oldest to eat you know so
all three musketeers that go eat that's
so interesting and when they sold this
yeah when they sit there the kids are
sitting there like the two twins taika
comes he's sitting there and he's in
there for maybe like a good two minutes
and then he start like you know like
pushing the plate around we're going to
select Circle the plate or he's just
he's starting to expand so
um when people they can Zone in and
focus and sink their roots in that to me
is how like regular people operate you
know they can focus and uh it's it's a
small tunnel and but it's deep yeah for
him his that's what they say about my
vagina
it's pretty deep yeah
I don't know if that's a good thing I
don't know why I said that
I like the smart that you had to yeah it
was like like you had the small dick
like yup wait a minute uh
do I want a shallow [ __ ] so then I go
oh it hurts
hurt or do I want like a deep [ __ ]
where I'm like nah I'll get it in there
son
I don't know that's where my I wish I
had ADHD because I would have stopped
myself before it came out of my mouth is
that what what how it works I don't know
I just based on what you're saying that
it's very shallow but it's like yeah
it's very shallow but it's wide so
that's why it seems like I don't want
that kind of [ __ ] it seems like they're
not paying attention yeah but they are
just to a lot yeah yeah yeah you know
what I mean so that's the it's the
definition with like what's your
definition of paying attention yeah that
definition defines
how they're focused yeah that's that's
when so specifically to last night
because that's when I had my aha moment
yeah was because I was explaining to you
I'm like man so specific to the letter N
I was working with taika to do the
letter N right so we start with the
stick top to bottom right so top to
bottom you pick up your pencil from that
same top you go to the bot to that um
diagonal line from that bottom point you
go up yeah there's your capital N yeah
cool it's an easy process one two three
boom boom boom he does he does it the
first two times after the second time
literally Seconds Apart he now starts
curving it or he'll make it really
really narrow and then I'm like dude
what happened I'm like just copy the
same thing and then when I was telling
you that you're like because I was
saying like it feels like I just lost
him like he just left and I have to be
like okay let's take a break dude let's
shake it off and then I feel like it's
like training a dog not to compare my
son to a dog but it feels like training
a dog like where they're just like you
know they're locked their their eyes are
locked on another dog and they're just
so focused guess that they're not paying
attention to what's in front of them
that you have to kind of like make a
turn with them so they just kind of snap
out of it I feel like I have to do that
with taika because I was telling you I'm
like I he just never pays attention
and you were just saying well it's not
that he doesn't pay attention it's he
already got it and once he understood it
now he's doing the the broad of the
shallow um content that we're discussing
which is the end so that's the
shallowness and now the broad Strokes of
everything else is okay can I make it
narrow can I make it curvy how many
other ways can I do this then and when
you said that I was like oh that's
[ __ ] crazy and I actually felt like
such a [ __ ] mom because I'm like damn I
was really just harping on them like
Focus pay attention what happened
so I can tell you the pros and cons of
it the pro of it is a lot of people
think like ADHD is someone getting
distracted oh he gets distracted so
easily it's so hard for him to stay on
task and to me it's actually the other
way around it's not a passive pull where
like someone's pulling away I view it as
almost like you're beaming it you're
pulsating it like for them when you have
ADHD it's not that other ideas are
pulling you off the task is you have so
many ideas that the singular idea is
starting to expand instantly so that's
the kind of the difference when you have
ADHD and this is in this you've compared
this description with other people that
have ADHD no this is my own personal
experience oh because I'm like it
doesn't sound like other people with
ADHD have described it that way I'll
explain I'll get to that after okay okay
so um the pro of it is
generally people with ADHD are extremely
creative because it's beaming like their
ideas are everywhere and anywhere so
once they hit this it goes like this
right which is why type A draws his ends
and then immediately he's like can I
draw squigglies in them can I make it
look like a certain way can I make this
part really big this part really small
and so the pro is ADHD people are very
very creative and they can reinvent the
wheel a lot so you'll see people in the
Arts
um or even like extreme sports
generally have ADHD and that's what uh
taika has where I think to someone that
doesn't have it you think that he's
getting distracted but he's not his
brain is already once he understands it
he's already Reinventing the way to do
it yeah the big big con to it though is
and this is where it becomes a learning
disability is because it only takes two
ends before he starts putting creative
ideas he doesn't have enough standard
reps in for the muscle memory to occur
because as parents that's what we're
trying to do you know like go ahead and
like draw up crazy n if you've mastered
the basics exactly but if you haven't
mastered the basics yeah don't go plain
like we've seen in Jiu Jitsu he
literally does two shrimps and it's not
even a muscle memory wax on wax off yet
and he's like waving to other people
he's like tickling other kids so he's
already expanding the way to do a shrimp
right can I do it like we've seen him do
push-ups like the coach said don't do
push-ups and he's like can I do on
tissue fingers yeah now he humps the
floor with this [ __ ] little hips yeah
now he's helping the forward's little
hips like he's already trying new things
so it's beaming with creativity and it's
not like he's getting distracted it's
the distraction comes from within
so now getting to the part where um
uh I didn't have I cross referenced this
with other people with ADHD I don't know
I'm one of the fortunate ones that I
feel like I found a way to harness it
because in traditional Society you get
pushed down so much I wouldn't be
surprised if a lot of people feel down
on themselves or they don't achieve what
they want because they don't get their
full potential because they go the only
way to get here is through this yeah and
since you don't learn this way you're
not getting there yeah that's a bummer
yeah how did you how are you able to
harness it like what how were you able
to harness it and then at what point
were you like oh [ __ ] it's harnessed
to be honest I don't think I harnessed
it until JK
yeah I think like as so like and we're
talking about like in your 20s yeah
that's not bad yeah I mean that's
maturity now right because like up until
that point you're an adolescent you're a
kid you're a child you're a toddler so
like you're still figuring out how the
world operates then you're figuring out
how the world how you operate within
this world and you're figuring out
yourself and then at that point you know
what what's happening in both of those
aspects and then at that point you're
just like okay this is how I fit in
maybe I also feel like I had multiple
chances to figure it out but my parents
just didn't really allow that because
when they're traditional and two they
probably don't have it yeah okay explain
all of it so like
um I think stuff like martial arts or
music or the Arts tends to lend itself
to ADHD thriving right because you get
to reinvent stuff because it's the same
thing and you get to reinvent things
right but how so if you're you're saying
again if you're a kid you don't have the
muscle memory
because you don't have the maturity to
say hey I need to put in these reps
because that's the only way I get better
so here's the other part to ADHD the
other part to ADHD is
um it requires a high dopamine hit for
you to be locked in ah [ __ ] hey
that's horrible which is why like
um I set like a chiropractor place on
fire because I'm like that is very
stimulating
you know what I mean when you explain it
like that it sounds [ __ ] you sound
like a pyromaniac I wouldn't be
surprised if a lot of Pilots have ADHD
because I think the theme because
usually for people it's like as soon as
they start getting better at something
the dopamine is going right and like
okay cool there's no drug addicts and
their dopamine means going and they're
able to keep doing it for like 30
minutes an hour people with ADHD
um they'll do it and it's literally no
hits so they're like oh whatever and
until they go but what if I do the n
with my left hand then it's like right
but then that dopamine hit goes away so
now they're like [ __ ] what else can I do
can I put the pencil in my mouth and
draw in my mouth you know so it's like
they have to constantly like to stay
focused so stuff that has higher Stakes
generally they're way more focused
because like the gambling because it's
hitting the dopamine yeah yeah
oh damn
that is [ __ ] rough yeah no wonder
your ass knocks out so fast at night
your brain's just [ __ ] ramped up yeah
so I had a chance to do like you know
martial arts I got really good at it at
a young age and then um
my mom didn't really want me to pursue
it obviously because you know like it
schools everything and then so like
extracurriculars outshining school is a
big No-No yeah the second chances I got
really good in Drums
um Drumline and then I wanted to go to
Berkeley School of Music so they know
like what kind of like career you're
gonna have with that so it took a lot of
trial and error to figure it out and
then it wasn't really and I think that's
why like once I graduated UCLA with
pre-med I was like
this is technically the most
accomplished I've been in the
traditional sense but it's the most
empty I've ever felt my entire life uh
um how are you even so pre-med is
already a heavy ass major someone with
ADHD and by heavy I mean like there's a
lot of studying that's involved in like
I want to say like 90 of your your
academic career is literally just your
nose in a book yeah how did you even
accomplish that I white knuckled the
whole thing oh [ __ ] how so drugs no it
just [ __ ] force myself how so I like
so that that's the other thing that was
like I don't know how the common
like the social the social like uh
consensuses on Adderall in 2023
um but back in 2000 eight 2009
like all my pre-med friends would take
Adderall to study oh [ __ ] it was around
in your era yeah what I didn't know
about it they literally be like I'm
gonna get my Adderall first and then
we'll hit the study group and to me I
always felt that being
self-contradictory I'm like how are we
gonna abuse medicine to get into
medicine
I always felt like that was weird so I
was like if I don't get into medicine
like naturally
then maybe I don't belong yeah but like
half of my classmates would all be on
Adderall and they don't even need it
well no they're they're they're guinea
pigs you know they're testing it out oh
yeah research yeah yeah pharmaceutical
research yeah yeah yeah it's scientific
yeah so um so during that time I would
just White Knuckle it it would I would
literally be like okay I have to [ __ ]
learn this chapter what can I do and I
literally tried everything I'll try
reading it and then it takes [ __ ]
literally 30 seconds before I read the
first sentence and my brain's going
awesome Ross or I'm like okay and then
what do you do so um that doesn't work
so I'll try like okay what if I read it
with the lecture so I started recording
lectures that actually helped out a lot
like having
um multiple stimulation yeah so I record
the lecture so I'll listen to it while
I'm looking at the notes that I wrote
that really helped out kind of like
getting like [ __ ] uh dogging dog
eating like what do they call it the
rotisserie chicken when you're getting
bone in the back and then the someone's
[ __ ] your mouth I don't know I don't
know whatever the rotisserie chicken
porn name is yeah all that let me let me
let me introduce [ __ ] two holes at
once just [ __ ] pound pound Pound and
and that really helped out or I'll even
go like I'm only gonna do spurts of like
uh
five sentences I mean a five minutes at
a time and I'll take a ten minute break
five minutes at a time to like almost
like uh doing some sort of like hit
interval training so give me a sentence
to memorize like right now um
okay so I'll be like all of the dogs all
of the dogs all the dogs all of the dogs
okay in Alaska in Alaska in Alaska
Alaska and Alaska although I was in
Alaska all of the dogs in Alaska and all
the dogs in Alaska and then I would like
can I write that down now okay cool all
the dogs in Alaska cool boom got that
memorized like to hibernate what else
did you say uh for uh for three months
okay all the dogs in the last like the
hybrid within three months so I would
just keep building like force feeding my
[ __ ] brain to [ __ ] get it until
like whatever I needed to memorize
whether or not I understood it I at
least memorized the word the sounds so
I'm not even thinking of all of the dogs
I'm just thinking
so I'm just like okay get the sounds
down three months like that happened in
three months and I would write off force
feed it and I'm like okay
okay okay at least I have that so now at
least I have the sounds memorized in my
brain now let's try to understand the
sounds all of the dogs in Alaska okay
cool that's considering like the whole
dog population okay cool they like the
hibernate for three months that means
they're active the other nine months out
of the year you know not trying to flip
the fours in black as for that like
that's how it would it would take for me
to [ __ ] learn something versus a
regular person like all the dogs in
Alaska and they go oh I get it I'm like
trying to like because if I'm reading it
the way this person read it like I'd be
like all of the dogs of KFC did I try
their new crunchy chicken yet it'd be
like it already like but that just goes
against what you just said happens what
um you already were distracted by
another thought yeah like you didn't
even go deeper into that's why I said
all of the all of the all of the the
dogs the dogs the dogs the dogs I don't
give my chance like if I know this is my
distraction or not this I don't call
this track but this is where I'm I lose
touch
with my task I keep it here oh [ __ ] you
know what I mean so kind of almost as if
like to put in meathead terms like let's
say you have to hit 10 reps yeah but you
know you give up after two reps so you
gotta do five sets of two yeah you know
what I mean only two reps bam at least
two reps bam release but you'll hit 10
reps by doing five sets of two yeah
other people can do one two I'll do all
the way to ten reps my arms give out by
two reps so I can't do it in one set
I'll do it in many sets I'll still get
the same amount of reps they need but it
took me a lot of the [ __ ] White
Knuckle the [ __ ] to get it done
yeah okay so were you aware at that
point that it was all ADHD working
against you or you were just like I
don't even know I was just like I was
just like man I ca I [ __ ] suck ass at
learning but apparently I'm [ __ ]
smart because that's what all my
teachers tell me and um because in class
it's different like in class literally
something's presented the teacher's
talking boom boom boom boom boom I get
it right away faster than anybody in
class we go home and then we come back
and we take the tests and people have a
deep knowledge of it and I'm like I
wasn't able to get that deep but in
class I [ __ ] got it you know because
I'm because like like the first two ends
easy you know like there's other kids in
class if they're teaching them how to
draw and they might take eight turn
eight times to get the end but then they
got it yeah Tyga got it in two times but
then by the eighth time the N is already
there's already squiggly squax it's gone
yeah it's a number eight yeah exactly
um so then moving into JK then where was
that moment where you're like oh okay
this is what this is who I am this is
what I have this is how I do it
um
I think it might not even have been like
it might have been like JK just kidding
news era okay because even in skits I'm
still learning like I'll still like I'm
gonna write it gets very structured this
is Theory whatever yeah and then anytime
I would feel myself like beam I would
like push that aside push that aside
like no no that's not right that's not
what the and then until I realized that
the beaming ideas were better than what
were the ideas that were on hand and
then I was like those are funnier so for
example like you know when we're riding
our skits and we shoot them we hit the
lines first then second third fourth
take our improv right the second take is
better third take is better fourth take
it's better because my brain is just
expanding instantaneously yeah and I was
like oh [ __ ] this is where I thrive
you know it's like it's during like The
Improv part and then so now I've been
able to kind of nurture this baby muscle
finally and then on JK news same thing
like now when we're having a
conversation you say something to me the
regular person is thinking about their
thoughts I already have five responses
so I get to almost pick and choose which
one I think is the funniest and I choose
that one and then I say that one that's
crazy and so that's why I like um
yeah like you know like the the whole
spinning car crash in the movie The Slow
Motion it feels like that like when when
we took our improv comedy class with
Rich Tyler Rico shout out shout out to
him one of the best uh comedy teachers
out there when he used the term you need
to have rolling visualization and improv
I really got that
because it's like you can't predict
what's going to happen but you have to
say something like as if you knew what
was going to happen because we'll have
the rolling visualization I'm like
that's literally what ADHD feels like
yeah when something happens like
literally it's presented before the next
person even finishes their sentence
like you have all these choices and you
choose that one and now we saw Ty could
do that little yesterday like he's got
side mounted and he could have braced
the juice anything but he decided to
stick his hand on the way though
[ __ ] bless you
you still have allergies yeah a little
bit yeah he's a funny guy okay so then
um I'm so grateful that I have you and
this is what I'm talking about that like
at the same time if you didn't have me
maybe your kid wouldn't have ADHD
yeah but then maybe I wouldn't be here
where I'm at now you know what I mean
like there's just so many like who cares
right
um
yeah because I definitely don't have
that but I'm so grateful that I mean I
have you because now like I get to have
this deeper understanding of it at such
a younger age because the way you
explain it to me you're explaining it to
me from someone that's already in their
30s and then I'm understanding it from
my 30s right but now I get to see it at
such an uncontrolled raw stage where I'm
literally making eye contact with him
like right now we're looking at each
other
seconds with him he's already like like
I could see him like fighting his eyes
to like come right back to make eye
contact with me like it feels like
there's just this Force that's like oh
that's way more fun but let me like move
like I could I could physically see him
struggling to be present yeah he's
getting the dopening dopamine hit
somewhere else yeah yeah yeah
so like if I didn't have you to like go
oh yeah I remember that time or whatever
like I think I would be drilling him
because I'd be like yo you got to pay
attention like I would be blaming myself
going like okay I'm not being structured
enough or strict enough or consistent
enough like so then I would start
harping on myself to be like okay you we
need to have like this little soldier
now I also don't think that's a bad
thing
um yes or no so it's not bad because of
course kids need consistency structure
and all of that but I'm saying to the
extent where now I'm only basing it off
of comparisons right so I'm basing it
off of kids that seem to be normal and
that's not fair to taika right because
now I might be stifling his creativity
or his growth or his confidence do you
know what I mean yes but also what I
learned from my experience is the world
isn't gonna be ADHD friendly overnight
the world is centuries old probably
thousands of years old in its ways
so he needs to plug himself into this
world too yeah so it's awesome that he
has parents that understand that part
and can help nurture that
but he also needs to walk into the bank
from the front door
not with the [ __ ] costume on yeah
talk to a teller you know have his debit
card or whatever he needs to withdraw
the money
you know what I mean like he still has
to do regular World [ __ ] he can't
descend upon it in a helicopter and go
what I'm just here to get my money like
he still has to do normal [ __ ] we live
in a normal world so to me like that
Drilling
he's gonna sit in traffic one day he's
gonna have to go to the DMV one day like
all those things are [ __ ] normal it
sucks it makes your skin crawl but I
also think there's a difference between
understanding your unique traits but
also still being adaptable to what's
happening then how do you go about doing
that and that's why I think us having is
such a good blend because I'm because we
teach we teach things different ways I
see we have different ways of talking to
him
um I like that he has his school I like
that he has Jiu Jitsu so he himself will
have his own like little counsel of
instructors that he'll naturally like as
he gets older and is more self-aware
he'll he'll be able to go oh I actually
learned better this way
you know so I think it's good I I think
it's it's uh or else if he just has one
teacher that does one thing it's going
to take him a long time before you know
what I actually learn better this way
like me when he's like 30 something yeah
or 20 something when I first started
learning
so then how do you contain it at this
age
like how do you contain it enough
to where you don't stunt anything but
then you're also there to help
um set the foundation for like the Reps
you know what I'm saying yeah so this is
uh what I learned from training which is
if people don't have endurance which
means they can't get in the Reps per set
you have to increase the amount of sets
so for example if you [ __ ] Meathead
dude but this is literally how you this
is literally how you're right right and
this is what I even taught in my
mentorship program this is literally how
you troubleshoot everything frequency
volume intensity you can learn anything
through through manipulating those three
variables so if we know
he can only do two ends at a time
and it's going to take let's say 20 ends
to get muscle memory
then he's going to have to do those two
ends ten times a day once in the morning
once during lunch once in the afternoon
you know and you'll end up getting it
and he won't feel fried because right
versus if he only can do two ends and
then three through twenty we're pulling
teeth and he's getting down on himself
that's not what we want because now
we're having negative side effects in
his other aspects of his life yeah but
if we keep it positive and he's
confident he'll still when he needs to
pull those ends out he can run him
perfectly yeah how do you do it in
school then because school is is
structured in a way where I feel like
it's even bad for just kids that are
normal where it's like kids tend to be
just kind of at a desk for an hour at a
time
well now what's kind of cool is seeing
that schools change yeah so they're
adapting like like at his new school the
teacher even talks about how they have
stations and they go for specials they
call they go from here and then they go
from there so they switch it up they
know that the kids need I need
simulation yeah even if kids without
ADHD just young kids and need breaks and
and switching it up on our end us
knowing how taika is I think us bumping
up the frequency is going to be great
like even my mom saw it when she was
staying with us trying to make make them
do math for an hour impossible but if if
she's like all right you go right down
the slope every time you come down the
slope it's on a scooter yeah yeah I'm
gonna ask you a question and so he comes
down the slope 10 times he answered 10
math questions yeah he's really good
yeah yeah he could do more like double
digit numbers in addition yeah he'll be
like Mom what's 10 plus 10 plus 10 plus
36 or something like that and then I was
like I don't know what is it he goes 62.
I was like oh [ __ ] 10 plus 10 plus 10
yeah plus 36 or third whatever it is 36.
it's 62. uh uh uh uh yeah that's what he
said I did this wrong I hope you know 10
plus 10 plus 10 plus 36 10 plus 10 plus
10 is 30. Right plus 36 yeah is what
oh is that six four five isn't it 62 no
it's 66 10 plus 10 plus 10 that's on the
right side is still zero yeah yeah yeah
so zero what am I saying 36 or 32 you're
saying 62. oh and I said 36 yeah oh my
bad I just I [ __ ] up the 36 part of it
okay yeah I was like wait a minute what
the hell's happening so did I say 38 or
32 I'm [ __ ] up you said 32 the answer
is 66.
three plus ten plus ten plus 36. yeah
yeah
six yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I for some
reason I keep seeing 32 in my brain oh
okay even though I'm probably saying 36
it's like kind of like what I'm telling
you to make a right turn I go left yeah
you probably got some other [ __ ]
I swear we all have some [ __ ] I got some
[ __ ] you got some [ __ ] too somebody I
absolutely I don't know what should I
have I don't even know if I care to know
what should I have you got some [ __ ] for
sure yeah I'm definitely not present
that's absolutely the truth because like
I'll see it in my brain you're even
getting it too but I'll see what I need
to do in my brain like for example
making a right turn I literally see the
car making the right turn but because
I'm already like on the next thought
moving on yeah I'm like yeah yeah I left
and I don't even hear it like yesterday
I told you I need to put the frozen food
in the microwave when I meant to say in
the freezer yeah you like put it in the
microwave in the garage was it the
microwaving brush or freezer in the
garage I don't even know what I like I
hear myself say it after and I go what
yeah yeah I'm a mess but yeah this has
been really eye-opening for me because
it not that you've concealed it for me
and I was just trying to [ __ ] be
funny when I said that in the beginning
of this podcast but
um you've just done such a good job at
just
looking like you're laser focused all
the time am I laser focused it seems
that way yeah it does oh man I'm
definitely not because you're quiet
you're to yourself I mean now I know you
probably have like 20 tabs open that
you're like researching a bunch of [ __ ]
all at once but I'm like damn he's like
because
you're not like Joe right like Joe needs
to get up and literally shake it out or
he needs to turn on music or like he
just needs to leave the room like that
to me is super ADHD yeah you know
whereas for you you're literally there
sitting there focused what appears to be
focused on the outside you're not
distracting anybody you're not even
needing to get up or leave yeah you
could sit there for hours and that could
be due to your mom taking you to be
[ __ ] a monk for a weekend you know
every weekend of your summer yeah
um that you just know how to live in
your brain yeah and be still I probably
just learned how to like cope with it
you know
is that like part of your ADHD whatever
you do now probably yeah
like I I realize like I have to like
keep two tabs open I have to text when I
drive no don't say that you son of a
[ __ ]
don't [ __ ] say all the choices I'll
say this one what were the other choices
I'm not gonna tell you no but I had like
um I always have to do something while
doing something else in order to
be focused at the one thing unless the
stakes are super high AKA Jiu Jitsu yeah
okay but like even when we first got
like uh what were like ATVs
I was way better at writing the ATV when
I was shooting the GoPro while at riding
oh really remember I mean that that
that's you driving you just suck at
driving or even like when I learned
scuba diving like literally even before
my certification I was recording like
with that underwater I was recording
um our scuba lesson underwater already
because it just helps me
okay for other people like oh my God
that guy's [ __ ] crazy he doesn't even
know how to do this [ __ ] but like it
actually helps me focus on two tasks
how does that work
is it because as soon as your attention
span is gone from as soon as there's not
enough stimulation in that one then you
just bounce to the other one
it's like a ping pong effect I think
it's
um something that has to do with almost
like
so another Meathead example
so
um like let's say uh you're trying to
work your back okay in a deadlift okay
and um people that are really quad
dominant they could technically squat
the deadlift yeah and because they can
do that they don't really train the back
yeah they they're not able to add the
volume to the back because their quads
are taking all the work so for someone
like that what you do is you have them
pre-fatigue the quads go crazy on like
extensions go crazy on lunges and then
once the quads are pumped and pretty
much useless
now you go do deadlifts and your back is
going to take the load so that's kind of
how I feel like I operate where I have
like too much bandwidth so when Once one
of it is preoccupied the other one can
kind of calm down and be focused like a
normal person
does that make sense it makes sense
in turns yeah
I just don't know what that feels like
so as I hear you saying that it gives me
anxiety and the only thing I guess I can
relate it to and be like oh okay I can
see how this works is when like what you
say like I'm in like my mom mode where I
can do like multiple things at once yeah
but I don't know if I can do them
simultaneously but it's also different
because you're uh
you're not exploring Everything at Once
no not handling everything else because
I I don't need to explore yeah yeah
because if I need to explore it then I
need to focus now ADHD or exploring a
bunch of things at once yeah so if you
can lock one thing in then
the other the other part of it for me I
could Zone in finally
yeah yeah because there's no way I'm
gonna explore so it's like like looking
for a [ __ ] a dress right like you
know how we like that it's funny that
like we have to turn like if we're
listening to the radio we have to turn
it down because we need to hear
ourselves think yeah it's like that when
I'm exploring yeah like I need to really
sit there be present quiet all the noise
around me and just like stare I didn't
really try to take it in once that once
it's locked in and I got it cool give me
10 of those things it's getting done
because I don't have to think about it
anymore it's just muscle memory now yeah
but I just don't understand how that
works
how well it works uh how you can explore
two things at once
no I have to like occupy my mind on one
thing and then the other one I can start
learning on this one
but you're saying you could so the scuba
diving GoPro example yeah
is it the GoPro that you already knew
that you're like okay this is kind of
like
like something that's keeping my muscle
working while I get to explore this one
kind of
it's like it's um that's wild yeah it's
weird because it's not like the only way
I know how to explain it is almost as if
I have too much bandwidth but I don't
really have too much bandwidth it's not
that like
um
because it's not like I can do too many
things it's not like I'm like superhuman
it's more so like
like let's say my arms and my that's why
the best example is the quads in the
back it's almost as if like I can't if
I'm if I'm trying to solve this Rubik's
Cube
but my legs are fidgety
I I can't I'm so distracted by my legs
but if I'm on a unicycle then all of a
sudden oh that's taken away then I can
like really focus on like the color of
these yeah it's like that oh my God but
it's not like oh he's superhuman and he
could like think like crazy and then so
like
um take away the unicycle he could do
everything it's like no it's like one
thing that's just extremely dominant
over the other and you have to like take
care of that first
okay so even in college the first thing
I had to do is like always jack off
it almost like takes away like
I don't know brings it brings it down a
little bit brings it being what's it the
[ __ ] fuzzies I don't know I don't
even know what to call it the ADHD
fuzzies what is a fuzzy I don't know I'm
just calling it something tick like a
like a like a itch yeah like it brings
the it brings the tunnel the world back
down and it's not why because you're
like off because you're like because you
got so much [ __ ] reaching out you just
jack off real quick and it's like
and then you can like kind of focus a
little bit longer so the jacking off
wasn't because you were horny it's just
because of the fuzzies probably horny
too those are 20s or whatever but
um but it also brings the fuzzies down
[ __ ] a so you're jacking off every
morning man guys are [ __ ] wild
probably like two three times a day
every day you have to oh my gosh that's
the only way I could like that's the
only one I was gonna get into UCLA
on your admittance letter like your
resume yeah I gotta figure it out I
gotta jack off or I'm not gonna get into
a good school
you didn't want to I don't want to but I
had to you had to [ __ ] get it done I
had to [ __ ] okay
all right well damn I'm really gonna try
really hard to pay attention to taika
and obviously keep in mind that like he
still has to live amongst us mere
mortals and like keeping that structure
consistency volume intensity all of that
while still trying to like be very aware
of like his ADHD he hasn't been you know
what he's doing things and he barely
learns how to do something is exploring
already it looks extremely dangerous I
almost never step in because I
understand the mechanism that's
happening what do you mean it looks
dangerous he's just like you know like
before he was deathly afraid of riding a
bike right he's like oh it's so scary
whatever and then like we're like come
on you could do it he could do it and
once he gets over that hump he starts
riding a bike and literally like two
rotations in he's like look at me he's
like sticking his leg out or like one
arm or whatever that's him learning it
he's a no but that's him preoccupying
one part of his mind and giving it
heightened Stakes so that he can do the
right thing
so from a regular parent like keep both
hands on The Handlebar you just learn
what are you doing right or even like
when we went ice skating
remember we went ice skating it's like
um he's barely learning how to do one
and two Glides look at me I could do
this I can go backwards and the regular
pair like no just stick to the one two
one two because that's what you're
saying we leave him alone we leave him
alone because he's gonna figure it out
his own way he has to go whoa and that's
him learning like how to do it the right
way so then is this something that you
would disclose with his future teachers
no they're not gonna understand
uh this is I'm at The Cutting Edge of
ADHD
you know what I mean like until you get
a guy that has a PHD
ADHD you know he's never gonna get it I
can't take my I know I could take my
anecdotal uh
evidence yeah somehow create a clinical
example of it it's just all technically
Bro Science you don't think they they
um they cover this in like Child
Development and stuff especially for
teachers like to get them prepared maybe
a little bit I can see I mean I could
see the way the teachers are now way
different than before yeah and it's like
you know it's like moving forward little
by little but it takes Cutting Edge
research
then someone uh
pushing for policy change and then for
it to be implemented in school so it
takes a long time yeah it does it really
does because you have to convince a lot
of people especially if they're old
school thinkers yeah do you think that's
what um I mean I don't know much about
the monastery
um
um what is it Origins yeah but do you
think that's probably what it was doing
too
it could be it could be they could just
see that maybe like traditional learning
is not right for a lot of kids that
don't like to move around and
um I think Montessori is more about like
uh kid guided learning where they just
where they just go like hmm and they're
like putting blocks together and like oh
you want to play The Box can you use the
blocks to spell e
you know it's like whatever they're
doing use that to learn I see that's
what I think the Montessori method is
you wouldn't want to open up a school
for ADHD folks I'm not probably get
distracted
everyone's gonna get distracted either
that or all jacking off I don't know
I said kids [ __ ] hey I don't
know if you want do you want to go to
UCLA or not I don't care no I don't want
to [ __ ] dude the day I walk in and
taika's jacking off I'm gonna [ __ ]
vomit I would be like
or you start finding weird stains in his
underwear you're like what I already had
the [ __ ] weird stains in his [ __ ]
under the front of the underwear
oh
God
thank God he's only five we have a good
what seven years six five six seven
years damn that's no time at all
you know that seven years yeah it's long
short time it is long short time because
it's not 10 but it's like it's getting
there yeah I think once you hit six or
seven it's like damn he's halfway to a
teenager holy [ __ ] I know our nephew is
is there he's 13 this uh in a couple
weeks I think he's as tall as me now
a lot of people are astologists a lot of
kids that's true oh man no but it's been
uh it's been a learning curve for sure
so we did do the behavioral psychologist
with him and she was even like hey for a
five-year-old she made it sound like
he's just like the special case yeah and
I'm like haven't you been doing this for
like over a decade or maybe two decades
like this can't be the craziest dude you
have like he doesn't seem that wild to
me like he has a lot of energy he's
pretty wild he is wild but he doesn't
seem abnormally wild right so remember
the kid that he had in his um Jiu Jitsu
class that had ADHD or like on an
extreme side of the ADHD I think that's
more than that well that's what his dad
told me no you got some other [ __ ]
um that he just was like barking and
like doing all this other stuff some
other [ __ ] yeah I don't know what the
[ __ ] he has but it's definitely more
than typo yeah I I she just made it seem
like for a five-year-old you know he has
like a lot of energy and stuff and I'm
like yeah I know like that's why we're
here lady yeah like specifically like it
just sounded like she was vent thing a
bit where I'm like
just give me your [ __ ] professional
like conclusion here yeah like don't
don't give me what I know yeah I didn't
pay you because I [ __ ] I know this
[ __ ] I see him I go look at these gray
hairs I get it
um but she's like yeah he's really
hyperactive so I just I'm really curious
to see if there's anything else at play
here
but it doesn't feel like it it just
feels like he just has ADHD maybe he
just has a lot of ADHD would you want to
put him on medication no why
um like I think this is my own personal
Theory I think whatever you have and
this is a very biological point of view
or a biologistic if that if that's even
a word but like do you know
um like Darwin's Law of natural
selection yes what is it
um
you know we're born with what could be
perceived as a defect or a mutation okay
I don't know bro I'm not a [ __ ]
science major but basically let me know
if I'm on the right track or not rule
number one
um
yeah so if there's a mutation or
whatever that's it's for adaptation
right or you die are you asking a
question are you telling me I don't know
you just [ __ ] gave me Forts and I'm
trying to like categorize it and give
you like four different pretty close
actually all right what
oh he died
like yeah I mean you cut me up there's
more because I'm [ __ ] kinky I don't
even know if I remember them but you
stupid son of a [ __ ] so the first one
is variations exist
right variations from the norm exist
that could be psychological that could
be physiological could be physical could
be genetic could be whatever but
variations exist duh number two
competition exists
right we have limited resources we have
limited mates for reproduction there's
competition in this world
number three the variation that is best
suited for the current competition Will
Survive we'll survive for example
um dinosaurs will not even be able to
exist in this day and age because now
our climate is a comfortable 70 to a
hundreds whereas I think during the
dinosaur era like it was like over 100
or 200 degrees so as huge as they are
you bring them to a common state here
they would be food freeze to death 70
degrees would freeze them to death so
they're not adapted to the current
competition so that's the third one and
then fourth the ones who win competition
get to reproduce cycle continues where
it starts back with variation right we
have kids we have five kids one's tall
one's short one looks more Mexican one
looks more Asian one might have ADHD one
might be extremely dyslexic like you who
knows [ __ ] off I'll I will [ __ ] and then
so it's off so uh and then they'll all
perform at varying rates right so what I
like to hone in on is number one
variation exists and it's meant for rule
number two and three which is to adapt
in this current society that we created
it's
we're forced to like have everyone be
the same yeah because that's easier to
govern it's easier to give policy and
it's easier for like no one wants to go
to a [ __ ] restaurant and like um
excuse me do you have this thing that's
made from that that's that it's made
from this that's free range and you're
like [ __ ] yeah you just have to
go to Hollywood [ __ ] yeah it's very
difficult right West Hollywood there
it's all like that so because of that I
actually think variation is beautiful in
my opinion whether it's autism Down
syndrome ADHD tall short everything if
you just look at it from a biological
lens
they're just genetic variations we
attach our own emotions to them like if
the Native Americans used to view Down
syndrome as like the happy people they
are almost never sat and they bring joy
to every tribe that they go to and so
they almost view them as like
um like demigods or spiritual creatures
right so like we attach our own emotion
to that so if I remove that to me I'm
like variation is beautiful so if you
know how to harness your variation and
turn your variation into a superpower
that is the most amazing theme that you
can do for yourself
you know so to me I wouldn't want to
chemically change what taika has it's
just up to us to help them harness that
and be able to channel that into the
world where it's productive
or he's just gonna be jacking off
everywhere
he could jack off before board meeting I
don't know just kidding possibly that
was really beautiful that was really
beautiful that you said that and I yeah
I couldn't agree more I would not I
would definitely not want to like
zombify him like I hate that he's taking
medication for seizures right now even
people that are like colorblind yeah
like colorblind to to like to our
Spectrum our eyes right yeah but I can't
see what they see but if they harness it
they there could be certain things that
they're able to create or produce or
perceive in the world in a much
different way right like Ray Charles he
couldn't see but his music was like
amazing yeah so to me it's like
I don't see things as less than or more
than I see it as okay it's just
different how do we Channel it you know
yeah
tight
well damn we've reached end of this
podcast
before we go
is there anything you want to know about
the normals the normies now I've been
studying my whole life
I know we don't sound as exciting as you
it's just exciting because to me it's
very peaceful
it's very like predictable it's
consistent it's stable
it's very like relaxing it feels like
the P like there's so much peace of mind
versus the way that like I operate which
is what like [ __ ] New York streets
I'm walking here the way that I operate
I feel like it's like roller coasters
and car crashes like every day what yeah
well I'm glad you've been able to
harness because you've been creating
such a beautiful life and you create
some really dope content
um and you're such a funny dude
that like I know type is in the right
hands because he has your genetics so
luckily for you you were able to like
figure out the answer key for your life
so now you can kind of share some of
those answers with me because you know
me I'm Mexican I don't study I always
just [ __ ] copy off of the Asian cat
always copy so give me those answers
because I need to help my my mixed boy
all right okay okay well thank you Bubba
welcome and thank you guys so much for
listening
um hope this was very insightful I'm
always learning so much from this
big-headed guy in front of me
um and if you are dealing with ADHD or
don't even know that you have ADHD
um but you can relate to what a lot of
Bart is saying I would just say like
take his tips pick his brain hit him up
on Instagram and stuff
um and and yeah let us know if there's
anything else you want us to cover in
the comments below like always we
appreciate you love you so much see you
next week bye bye